okay so my name is Pierre Boulle I run a
small Norwegian startup called include
OS so who here has heard about include
OS before Wow sorry
that's Wow that usually doesn't happen I
think like for the first time yesterday
in another talk somebody else referred
to include OS and I almost peed myself
that was so that was really very cool
okay so so we creating we our company
what we do is we create this operating
system or this non operating operating
system and to sort of give you a sort of
a bit of an understanding of what we do
and why we do it
we'll start by sort of a short history
of computing as it'll be very short so
so roughly the 50s punch cards 50s and
60s punch cards so systems were batcher
entered however they were sort of in in
terms of pure efficiency they were very
very efficient cause you would you would
write your program onto a stack of cards
you would submit that to and then during
the night it would load and you would
have the entire computer at your
disposal and there was nothing else
running on it like nothing absolutely
nothing no there wasn't like operating
systems yeah
however the user experience was
absolutely horrible you sort of left
missing semicolon on line five you would
figure that out the next day because
your data just weren't there and there
was a compiler error instead so then
during the 70s so I saw this picture at
least once on yesterday this is the the
the dec pdp-11 was the system where a
UNIX was born and of course though these
things were computers at that time were
quite expensive
so I think like the deck was about
$100,000 sort of if you got it with with
a reasonable set of peripherals and you
had to share it and in order to share it
that there was a sort of a new concept
at the time this sort of first attempt
that sort of virtualization accepted
sort of virtualization it wasn't what we
think of as virtualization today but we
they created a virtual system which was
your sort of shell and your process
space and that was yours virtual
computer of course today what we were
require for a virtual computer is that
that virtual computer is more or less
identical to a physical computer but
they sort of this this virtual computer
in in interface so computers weren't
from being single process to being
multi-user and to an multi process and
of course the overhead the office was
was really horrible I think like up to
20% of the of the cycles were lost we
ended up at the end of the empties with
basically this design where we have user
space and in kernel space and the kernel
we talked to hardware we police users
and processes the applications running
in user space so on Intel that's ring
three and ring zero in the middle and
then we have that barrier there that's
supposed to sort of secure it it turns
out it's a bit porous and it also
completely kills performance so
previously I worked on for almost ten
years I worked on a project called
varnish cache and and sort of one of the
sort of absolute rules of stuff
developers couldn't do is talk to the
operating system unless you really
really have to because like we were sort
of handling an incoming connections and
they were typically coming at speeds of
10 to 20 to 30,000 per second and if you
sort of talk to the operating system to
get some memory
things might queue up and you'll be dead
so but that design they're like how
relevant is it really because like most
systems aren't multi-user systems
anymore like the systems we deploy in
Amazon like how many of them have more
than one user like I don't know maybe 1%
or something I think it's rather rather
quite few of them because we sort of
moved completely that that moved away
from using those facilities in the
operating system like most people today
they write an application and they
deploy it on a fresh set to virtual
machines I can like tonight is where we
had the server and I would write a
little silly web app or something and
then it would be deployed on the server
yeah of course
this thing is likely not multi-user and
multi-process as well yet we still use a
multi-user a multi-process operating
system so now let's get to include or so
what what exactly is it so basically
it's a library like most of the
functionality is in libraries and those
are sort of provide different ethernet
drivers there's some firewall called
memory management IP stack etc and the
idea is that when we build your
application what we do is inject parts
of those libraries into your application
so so basically we look for system calls
and instead of system calls we inject
library calls and the supporting library
so whenever the operating system
whenever your application was supposed
to do a system call it will do a we slap
a bootloader on it and off we go so so
this is typically what sort of how and
your application typically what it looks
like when it's linked on Linux it has
some application specific libraries
which links against generic libraries
which against the kernel and like our
systems where we have
bootloader there's some it's all in a
single binary single elf binary yeah
yes so there are a few things that are
sort of so refer to these systems as
Ewing kernels I would say that we are
sort of try to be the pragmatic unicorn
so we we sort of from an engineering
background the the code is written in
C++ we are happy to support multi-core
systems we sort of we're not really that
opinionated about what you do on top and
we are perfectly fine with running on
bare metal but I think like most of it
is because includeds was written after
sort of para virtualization wasn't that
thing anymore he went to have gone back
to sort of full virtualization again
which basically means that it wasn't
really that much of an effort to move to
booting on physical hardware okay let me
see if I can try to demo this done
because like that's like what I really
would like to see happen is that you
sort of go away here without
without being afraid of the system
itself so I stay out of the editor wars
so we are Emacs my I use cat
it isn't as quite sophisticated light
and editing and it's definitely
underrated as an editor so you see now
where the product has its name this 90
degree angle with the keyboard isn't
really ok the current volume is 100%
thank you yeah well I don't need to
explain that I think most of you know
enough see to so boot is the command we
grabbed to sort of boot up an instance
there's nothing else called boot as far
as we know so it sort of grabbed that it
needs superuser privileges in order to
set up networking so if it wasn't that
it wouldn't yeah so basically this it
built an operating system sort of
perhaps the world's simplest operating
system the hello world operating system
and booted it up in a VM and it says
hello world and then sort of halted
so like would would stuff we made I
think we succeeded in making the simple
stuff simple there's yeah I think that
would be honest said was make the hard
stuff possible okay so so I will now
come to the first party trick that we
have something called live update so
this came out of the need to sort of
continuously develop software and you
sort of deploy and to piñas to do that
because you're running a vm need to shut
down the vm replace the binary image and
i'm britta to back up again
so since basically what's running inside
the VM is basically just a sort of
stream of bytes sort of that's a
gigabyte of of bytes we can sort of it's
we can basically replace stuff that's
that's happening happening there sorry
so this is a virtual machine that's the
current sort of application that's
running there so there's a map of the
memory whenever it boots up it has the
option to connect to a master no the
management node so it we topped it
establishes the node to the to the
master the master can then sort of push
down an image and updated image through
that connection so now have the
situation where a virtual machine we
have to basically copies of the
application except one is updated and
one is not basically what we can do then
is we can basically just store the state
of the current operation of the current
running application and like sterilising
state is quite a common thing to do now
just store it at a very sort of specific
state
and then what we do is just actually
just boot the new kernel and then we
restore the state and then we sort of
discard old stuff and and discard this
as well and what has happened now is
during a broad 100 milliseconds we have
replaced a hundred percent of the
running code with completely new code
and there's nothing left of the old code
so it doesn't necessarily just limit
itself to updating we can completely
change what's inside of that sort of VM
we actually use this when so we have a
sort of commercial product where we do
firewalls and load balancers and what we
actually do at the way that that works
is that we built up these blank VMs that
have no functionality except this live
update functionality and then whenever
the sort of customer decides they want
that fire Walter would this specific
firewall set they just push it out
through this mechanism
yeah so so this is the let's do another
demo I think this will be tricky cuz
yeah
it's not the brightest application oh no
to work it out quite well I think
okay so let's see so what a boot up here
is an IRC server and we can
why did this work let's see oh it's a
robot yeah it is but it was oh he said
connection fish that of course there we
are
yeah well it's bit there's this s kid
yeah you can perhaps tell that it says
include OS or something here okay
excellent it works so that this is now
sort of a running IRC server and on the
running our AC connection to it great
this thing here the message of the day
is actually sort of hard-coded it's
compiled in to the application itself
what we'll do is we'll just know it's
called
yeah would you like to cool
okay I'm probably pressing buttons yeah
okay hello
check down and then we what I do now as
I rebuild the pract and create a new
binary and then I have a completely new
new binary of that system and then we
have an update script which is basically
just yeah it does the build on
everything's I didn't have to do that
yes the server sends out a servant note
this when it's updated and of course
I'll use too much time and it idly
closed down I closed down the connection
but you did perhaps notice that the TCP
connection did actually survived the
update so we had sort of so we did
actually manage them to sort of retain a
TCP connection and sort of still replace
all of the running code yeah I should
have done this a bit faster and would
have been a better demo so that's our
our party trick any questions so far by
the way we have quite ample of time so
feel free to interrupt me if you have
any questions so comment there's also
sort of so concurrency is is also sort
of sort of topic that's opinionated
within this sort of unicron community
most people think that the unique kernel
should only have like a single core and
should only run sort of non-threaded
event and then based applications as I
said we're not really of that opinion so
what will we since also one of our
targets is sort of bare metal hardware
just being able to just run on one core
would be just silly so the way that we
we used to have multi-core SMP support
and then this year we sort of broken it
and we decided to sort of leave it out
until we fixed some other stuff because
it's not really that much demand for it
but the idea rough idea is is this that
you have life fall for CPU system it'll
sort of boot up and just like include us
has an event loop so that's what we'll
do when
booted up is sort of to stay in that
event look and basically what happens on
sort of SMP systems is that they all
basically run this event loop and then
you have this ad task function where you
can basically just take a function call
and direct it at the specific CPU and it
will run on that and I'm sure sort of
wicking will at some point create
abstractions on top of that and I think
I offered this sort of been planning to
sort of get POSIX likes threads and have
being me being able to create POSIX like
threads on top of that with of course
the limitation that that that we cannot
have more threats than we have CPUs like
process preemption is currently sort of
not on the roadmap it's not that it sort
of magic or anything it's just sort of
vastly inefficient and I think like
Alfred is a bit doesn't like that okay
about developing would would include us
and what is sort of offers to developers
so as I mentioned that the native
interfaces store all event-driven that
also means that that I mean for would
we'd see you have the sort of standard
POSIX interfaces that you can sort of
use if you want to do stuff event-driven
in C++ we basically have no standards as
far as I know there's the art it's not
really standard so so the the networking
api's are sort of proprietary to include
wise yeah there's no scheduling there
are there is multi-core support the big
project we've been working on non I
would say probably most of the year has
been replacing the C library so you used
to run a little library called new Lib
which i think is very popular in
embedded amongst them embedded people
it's a very minimalistic
minimalistic see library so doesn't
really offer much except yeah except
what it had it has to muscle is a sort
of interesting project because what it
does is in addition to offer offering a
standard celebrate it also offers POSIX
which is quite rich on top of the of the
C library
we've tried implementing parts of POSIX
previously when we had new lib it's a
soul-sucking experience to implement I
have no idea why the people who did
write muscle actually implemented all of
POSIX on top of it I'm very impressed
that they did but the nice thing is that
we can now unlock parts of POSIX as as
long as we come can provide the
underlying system called like
functionality that muscle expects mostly
exact is sort of written explicitly with
Linux in mind so another operating
system coming cheekily along and taking
it and using it wasn't probably planned
but but what muscle expect is just for
there to be sort of linux like system
calls beneath it and there's if we can
provide those it will sort of unlock the
relevant parts of caustics so this means
that it's we should at least have enough
POSIX that you can run all of the
libraries that you like l beasts
yet some time before we can say that the
same thing about applications
applications do things like forking and
and stuff like that which doesn't
necessarily make sense on on include OS
but at least the applications should
should be available yes
debugging also also sort of slightly
different it's more akin to to embed it
I mean we do it cross compile when we
compile an application so that means
that that that you you might want to
sort of bring your own divine stuff into
your application so I mean there's
there's the are the developers that work
with us that this sort of printf style
debugging that's their favorite thing to
do you can actually attach gdb to to
sort of running VM that runs include wes
and and then you can sort of single-step
and set breakpoints another thing that
is that we also have a linux compile
target where we would basically just run
inside a Linux process and instead of
PCI device for networking we just get
packets in and out of the tap device so
I think like that's that's probably
likely the the easiest way to sort out
because then you have basically very few
limitations on on what you can do sort
of tools you can use okay so yes yes yes
yes there's only one address space is
virtualized um there's paging yeah but
its own bits but it's all that there's
only one it's only one one one address
space yes
- another dereferences yes oh I should
have probably repeated the question yeah
yeah was like does do all the CPUC all
the same stuff can you pause references
back and forth and pointers yes you can
yeah this is also did you have actually
discussed by the way of having like
several address spaces so one of the
things that that sort of we could
potentially do which is actually could
be quite cool is so it's running in ring
zero cause like and some people find
that scary because you can sort of
modify the page tables when you run
there I don't really think it's scary
because like like if that gets
compromised everything will become get
compromised anyway so it doesn't really
matter and you is still trapped inside
the VM so I don't but but there is an
opportunity to actually built up in ring
zero and then do it another unicorn over
in ring 3 which then doesn't have that
opportunity to modify its own page
tables that of course would wreak havoc
on sort of live update and we need to
rewrite quite a bit but then if that
gets compromised it wouldn't even be
able to alter the page tables okay
so what can this be used for Network
functions so these are so back in the
day we start physical switches in load
balancers and firewalls today
datacenters are mostly virtualized they
run with fair or yeah something like
that OpenStack yeah some sort of thing
and of course the networking functions
are virtualized as well and so the first
thing we actually did as a sort of
commercial company was trying to build
something was was look at sort of load
balancing of firewalls we're gonna try
to do that a firewall is after all just
a router we already had the router
I fire the the firewalls defaults pulse
is just not draft packet and the routers
policies route packets
how hard could that be we started off by
sort of if you look at sort of the way
traditional firewalls are built this is
they do have like these firewall rules
basically just a linked list of rules
and as a packet comes in
it gets basically shoved through that
list and if it's sort of if it matches
something happens we accept it or reject
it now when we sort of started working
with this how do you this means we have
to have some sort of configuration file
or something that we have to sort of
load and then reload it and there was
yeah I didn't really sort of there was
something wrong with it so what we did
and I've proposed this for talks next
year because I think it's it's really
cool use case or cool cool design so we
created this super simple
domain-specific language where we yeah
so allowed ports that's basically a list
of these ports this is a list of hosts
who can a list of everything and then
the first firewall rule if so if feed
source address is in nice sauce then and
if the TCP destination port is in allow
destination port we accept the packet
like it's super simple it's actually for
those of you that dealt with IP tables
rules it's actually a lot more pleasant
to read this stuff than to read the IP
tables rules so what you actually do is
we we compiled a transpile this to C++
and then we link it into the binary and
and the packets basically run native
code this sort of traverse through the
rules so for us this is actually simpler
to handle then I would say probably a
traditional configuration file but one
of the things it's it's also a lot more
friendly towards the CPU
so yes so I was a la Metropolitan
University there was a master student
error that the comparative analysis so
this is this is Linux these are the
number of firewall rules and this is the
throughput measured in gigabytes so out
of the gate we do it like 10 12 percent
faster attempt 12 percent faster than
the next already but as the number of
rules increase Linux has to shove that
single packet through that enormous Lea
long long list and it sort of slows down
and and I think like you can see sort of
where that list starts to wreak havoc on
the CPU cache it's a I think it's like I
like here doesn't the entire list
doesn't fit anymore and things go really
downhill from there whereas we still at
that we basically don't notice that we
have to process these 5,000 rules yeah
yeah there's a quick note on EBP F and n
F tables I think IP tables will be
dragged behind the barn and shot at some
point in the near future
and replaced wood wood better stuff
enough tables and EBP F are two of the
proposed solutions to it but that do you
have to say that that I think like the
firewall was built in a matter of two
three months and these projects are at
least 10 or 20 times more complex and we
offer the I would say probably a better
performance yes
another yeah so that's what we've been
doing today what we'll do in the future
is cpu-based IOT so I mean IOT you can
roughly divided into microcontrollers
and CPU stuff microcontrollers I think
like all the people I talk to they seem
to be really reasonably happy they have
a choice of relevant operating system to
choose from and they work reasonably
well for CPUs there's basically Linux
and qnx and not really not happy about
those those choices basically because of
the the a core feature of UNIX which is
the ability to reconfigure the system so
this made a lot of sense for of all UNIX
systems that are servers or desktops or
mobile phones or even T's but that you
can sort of the user can reconfigure the
running system however in my opinion
does not make any sense at all
for four devices so but who might have a
Wi-Fi router it runs Linux I can an
attacker if he finds a flaw in that
piece of software
he and which leads to remote code
execution you could actually reconfigure
that system to do something else so it
could like sniff packets or mined
bitcoins or do ya spam bots or do
something else which I don't really see
the need for that I think like 99% of
the people buying or Wi-Fi access points
they don't want that device to change
functionality or or at least they don't
want any user to be able to add
functionality to that system of QC of
course the vendor decides that it should
have more functionality and I think
that's this there's a similar situation
for a lot of sort of cpu-based IOT
devices Linux is I would take probably
in very few situations to right choice
basic because of that reconfigurability
yeah that's wrong with the with the
migrate for the general purpose
operating system so this summer we have
some awesome news we got a significant
chunk of money from the European Union
from the horizon 2020 program to
actually port include os/2 arm and to at
least get a couple of sort of boards
open running within with include OS so
hopefully or maybe in around a year we
might be sort of looking at sort of
booting up on arm stuff yeah but like
likely 64-bit cortex a ok ultra-low
latency so so they're like if there's no
operating system there's nothing that
can get in the way or it's very sort of
explicit what could be in the in the way
so when an interrupt fires we can
actually respond to it quite quickly
actually we over over beers yesterday we
discussed the situation of maybe you
should just turn off interrupts and
maybe just busy wait when we have
nothing else to do like because why not
because there's nothing else on that
system so we might as well visit wait
which means that the moment there's a
packet we can process it right away so I
was to on a talk where well
high-frequency trading was discussed and
it's been interesting to hear how much
effort is being put into sort of
disabling Linux because that's basically
a lot of what these people do they do
try to disable Linux they because they
don't use the networking stack they
bring their own into the application
they don't maybe not even using the iOS
stack you have user space describers
they sort of disable completed or try to
disable as much as of scheduling as
possible because they don't want
anything else
the try to disable as much of the CPU
cache as possible trying to pin pages in
the cache et cetera which is this sort
of but if you don't have if the or if
you have if you have a non operating
system operating system all of that is
already done because we never sort of
implemented those features anyway yeah
so have a really good latency response
and it will be interesting functions of
service has been sort of mentioned as a
case I think that's for me it's mostly
an academic exercise
since I don't own Amazon I I can't
really sort of make create a function as
a service platform because nobody
luckily use it because like just just a
function as a service platform doesn't
really bring that much value unless you
have all the other services around
there's a good example of of this
current industry problem where unless
your your Amazon Google or Microsoft
infrastructure innovation doesn't really
likely happen a lot of it yeah
general-purpose
api's we can use this for IRC servers or
there's a web-based a web toolkit that
we also created yeah we'll see if that
sort of catches on it sort of for that
to be a happen you have to actually want
to write your your API is in C++ and
people don't seem to do that anyone here
does that like Web API in C++ yeah so
what's happening in the future
arm 64 support the reason we say arm 64
is just because the muscle library was
written first they were likely the
32-bit version and he wrote the 64-bit
version and the 32-bit version is hard
for us to sort of plug in to our build
system because it was not as elegantly
designed bare metal support will likely
improve so there are there's stuff we
need to add so currently we have three
ethernet drivers one of them is
available as a physical card which is
the 8,000 driver will likely either look
at solar flare or Mellanox and see if we
can add support for one of those two
cards so we can try to sort of
play with ultra-low latency applications
yeah we should like that some point add
more hyper versus support so currently
we run on Linux and VMware so Linux is
KVM basically so that is most of the
market the new Amazon instances we can
run on them what we don't run on is is
sin and hyper-v yeah so if anyone really
wants to see us on hyper-v come and see
me and we can talk about it yeah yeah I
think that is it none of us know
anything about arm and we just got a
[ __ ] ton of money from the support our
software to arm so so if anyone here
like to spend a couple of years porting
a brand-new operating system to arm I'll
be very happy if you can come and see me
yes yeah I think the recurring theme
from Alfred's talk yesterday was we have
no idea what we're doing okay any
questions no questions really yeah yes
yeah so so the question was do you have
any figures for ultra-low latency
applications and so so there's a yeah
because of the interrupt got them
interrupt controller on the computer in
the office we haven't got networking to
work on bare metal yet because there's a
MSI X controller which is the fancy way
of routing interrupts and we don't
support that yet unfortunately but what
we have done is run the stream
benchmarks which are these these really
combination of computation and memory
bandwidth benchmarks what we saw was
that on average like Linux would
would run one benchmark in 33 cycles and
not entirely sure why but we would run
for me in 32.7 with 0.3 cycles
better there's some noise that is
typically introduced by sort of various
hardware inside the computer we do a run
like a percent faster than Linux on pure
memory based workloads which i think is
quite cool we have to see how the the
event model handles external interrupts
yes and yes so the question was about
user interfaces and graphics on bare
metal we do have support for SVG a frame
buffer so I think like there was this
guy who sort of ported so some retro
games to include OS so those work I
guess that's not really what you're
interested in I know that there have
been some people in the cute community
that have looked at include Wes for
basically embedded devices with screens
that could look a look at running
running cute that's all I know
that there been interest there okay it
is cute what you're after
yeah I thought so any other questions
[Music]
yeah so this is an existing application
or an existing library yeah Alfred
[Music]
the question was was compiler yes yeah
Clank five or 5:01 nothing like that was
it yeah six rate as well okay yeah yeah
it's not too painful yeah it creates
slow code but it's predictably slow code
it's not as fast as GCC six yeah so if
we build with GCC it builds nicely just
doesn't do it
[Laughter]
so I think we're at the point in time
where we should end so thank you very
much if you have any questions please
grab me Alfred